scp-096 versus scp-3008  096 may be able to tear almost anything  apart but does it have the mental  strength to put together an ikea  shelving unit without going insane this  is the shy guy versus the infinite ikea  this flat pack labyrinth has trapped and  claimed many a soul the maze-like inner  structure is only made more hazardous  with the inclusion of the staff an army  of faceless humanoid creatures eager to  kill anyone left inside after dark  however not only does scp-096 not need  food to survive it's unlikely that the  staff would do any meaningful damage to  it and it would probably rather enjoy  being trapped in a giant warehouse with  fewer people to see its face but if  someone looked at a photo of it on the  outside the psychic link would allow it  to intuitively know which direction to  run it and escape the infinite ikea  immediately it's safe to say we're  giving the win to the shy guy